we can't replace what's been lost Sonia
- send out the entire field team
we're not leaving metropolis until we
find it excuse me mr. Corton I know
tonight was just another Ted Kord
fundraiser but you were surprisingly
quiet where there's something I need to
talk to you about hey everybody its
charlie you may have heard about the
rumor that's going around about Ted Kord
coming to arrow a lot of people are
thinking that they're gonna do a version
of the Blue Beetle because of some
casting notices some things that Stephen
Amell has said in some things that
they've done in the past
there's even an Easter Egg that goes all
the way back to season three on arrow so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos there's gonna be a bunch of stuff
happening this summer between this and
Titans there's also a new round of that
Legion ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so the big deal is
that arrow is casting a couple new
characters for the new season to bring
in not including the Batwoman so like
she's obviously a big character that
everyone's been talking about but before
the season started Stephen Amell said
we're debuting a new character who when
I heard about it I just got goosebumps
so he's talking about like a really big
comic book character that they're
introducing then we got the casting
notice it's for a man named Daniel
Porter which is a fake name just to
mislead people so that it doesn't give
away who the character is actually going
to be he's supposed to be a dude in his
mid-30s so just like a little bit older
than Oliver an intelligent tech
entrepreneur whose creativity has given
him huge success as a businessman he's
gone through tragic losses in his life
something that he hides from the people
around him thus struggling with shaping
new relationships with others the reason
why people are thinking that this is
going to be Ted Kord is is because
there's this three levels deep Easter
Egg that goes back to Brandon a Ralph's
character when he was first coming into
the arrowverse when they were casting
him the description for the character
read a lot like this new Daniel Porter
character in the name for his character
on arrow was also coded as Daniel an
Easter Egg for Dan Garrett the first
version of the Blue Beetle from the
comics so when people read about this
brilliant tech entrepreneur that's
giving Stephen Amell goosebumps because
they're debuting him on
and he has a tragic past people are like
wow well they mentioned Ted Kord so many
times on arrow in the past what if they
were actually bringing him on the show
finally like you have that shout out
from Moira that was way back during
arrow season one then a lot of you will
remember that Cort Industries has shown
up a lot on arrow not Ted Kord but cord
industries
anytime a big criminal organization or
someone like Slade's mirakuru soldiers
needed to steal weapons they would steal
it from court industries because they
also deal with weapons but it sounds
like they can actually bring the
character in he can help them fix their
rebuilding problem that they have in
Star City like right now it's overrun
with crime there's just all kinds of
crazy stuff going on so Oliver needs to
fix the city after he gets out of prison
then there's this whole other ongoing
storyline in the arrowverse with
felicity and curtis making this new tech
company there's smoke industries this
part of this future timeline that we
travel to on legends of tomorrow so that
is this whole tech side to the arrow
verse that we haven't done a whole lot
with in the last season and that's
really where Ted Kord comes in so he can
sort of straddle both of those
storylines he can basically pick up the
baton from where Ray Palmer left off
when he went on to legends of tomorrow
because the whole thing with them not
being able to use Ted Kord originally is
that Brandon Routh was supposed to be
Ted Kord but then the network was like
we have other plans for the Ted Kord
Blue Beetle character they were gonna
put him in that Booster Gold movie which
I'll talk about in a second so the last
minute they just changed the name to Ray
Palmer and pretty much used him for the
exact same storyline they were
originally gonna use him for he built
the atom suit then he went on to legends
of tomorrow the rest is history
but if you guys didn't know the big
thing now that's changed that might make
it okay for them to use the Ted Kord
character is that the Booster Gold Blue
Beetle movie was essentially pushed off
the schedule it still exists there's
still a version of it that Greg Berlanti
says that they're going to make he's
developing it with a writer named Zack
stents they already have their scripts
so like it's good to go
but because the tone was so different
from what the DC movies will look like a
couple of years ago they just weren't
sure where it was gonna fit in or how
they were gonna try and tie it in with
the continuity of the DCU but because
all those things got rescheduled and
they're sort of reimagining the creative
behind the movies I think the idea is
that they're just chilling on the idea
of withholding the Blue Beetle character
from the TV universe so naturally
because the arrow verse has already
developed the character quite a bit why
doesn't he just walk in one day and say
hello my name's Ted Kord I'm here to fix
all your problems and I also just happen
to be a vigilante the Blue Beetle and he
also would work perfectly on the flash
but again the reason why people are
thinking this Blue Beetle rumor is gonna
pan out is because of the whole Daniel
thing and just the way that backstory
breeds the other really funny Easter egg
if you guys go to conventions Stephen
Amell tells stories about his life
before the air overs he told a story
because they used the character on
Smallville in that booster episode is a
really funny episode I mean obviously
Smallville very different from the tone
of what the arrow verse does but Stephen
Amell himself said that he auditioned
for the role of Booster Gold way back on
Smallville so many years ago he said
that it was for the best that he didn't
get the role just because he wasn't
ready for that kind of thing at the time
but you can kind of see how Stephen
Amell looks a little bit like the actor
who ended up playing Booster Gold but
what they were doing was an older
version of Ted Kord who was passing the
mantle in the Scarab to Jaime Reyes
so if you remember how they introduced
Barry Allen on arrow and then he went
off to the flash TV show it was
Smallville doing their version of that
with Blue Beetle
whoa dude
who are your first
[Music]
hi
so you can kind of see that special
effects weren't where they needed to be
to do a really good version of that
character but it was a pretty solid idea
and obviously he's a big character on
Young Justice so let me know in the
comments just based on all these
mysterious Easter eggs and what Stephen
Amell is saying do you think that this
Daniel person that they're casting is
gonna wind up being Ted Kord if he gave
Stephen Amell goosebumps I think that's
really the linchpin if he was just
nobody special Stephen Amell will
probably like oh you know we got a
couple characters coming on it's gonna
be pretty nice when he says something
like oh man when I heard that we were
gonna introduce this big character and I
got goosebumps
it really does make it sound like it's
gonna be a big comic book character the
other question to ask - is this are they
going to include all these big new
characters they just introduced in the
crossover when they introduced the
Batwoman character or are they gonna
keep that relatively small because we
have Constantine on legends of tomorrow
how could you not include him in the
crossover and you have Barry's daughter
on the flash
I'm really hoping they introduce her to
Oliver and the other characters so Barry
could just have that awkward
conversation trying to explain how it is
that she exists here he'll be new Marvel
later tonight but leave all your
requests in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Chicago critic please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for all my flash
season 5 teaser videos and click here
for a brand new ant-man in the wasp
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight